[Music]
in fatal love triangle news doing a
mukbang over here
a mukbang is basically you eat food and
you talk so it gives us experience that
you're eating with the person and I
heard that it started off as something
really cool but I could be wrong about
this but I know that a few people said
that it's like some people be on diets
and they would watch and enjoy some
people for other people
foods like food porn food it would be
like you're hanging out with like a good
friend that's eating and enjoying their
food in this great conversation without
you having to you know that friends do
you to get new dudes on they're the ones
that I've seen it's usually like some
kpop looking boy they need to get like a
redneck truck driver with the beard
that's like 300 pounds in Korean mm-hmm
yeah so pun I guess it doesn't mean room
it's for pun so or it means like
broadcast yeah so monkeys eat well eat
broadcast but I want someone looks like
he knows is it one of those things where
people can pay you to like eat more
so yeah in Korea there was a there are a
few people who are still are where they
they actually donate money and they get
paid very well to do this like I'm
talking about high six figures I
understand it because the other day I
made a steak and then I was watching cow
farming a woman is now on trial for an
alleged love triangle which resulted in
the death of her husband almost 17 years
ago oh no what happened
this [ __ ] is crazy it's like her lover
was like oh my husband you had to kill
him so we could be together is that what
happened pretty much okay I knew it
so skeptical you must be stupid huh
stereotypical like but
[Laughter]
so it's about these three people Denise
Mike and Brian well the most basic
[ __ ] names ever on a JK news article
Denise Brackett bright is really bright
anyways Brian and they look really basic
they do they look babe and Laura does oh
they don't look like an idiot
they look like Iowans that looks like
Steve Carell he's squint really [ __ ]
hard yeah it's really racist of you Matt
not all white people look alike Nathan
Mike were married she looks nothing like
that they were highschool sweethearts
they also went to high school with Brian
and his ex-wife so all four of them went
to high school together all four of them
like growing up like they got married to
each other and then they had kids and
then they would go vacation together
all this led up to the point where
Denise started having an affair with
Brian wait I'm so confused is that the
same chick is that the same guy and they
do look the same no different guys same
shape same girl so that guy's not a good
guy is the same person who is dead oh
this guy killed him and he was his best
friend
Oh Ryan was Mike's best friend and he
killed Mike to be with her forehead is
huge but if you think back here right
like huge back house had been as I have
a big forehead she kind of looked
related to Britney Spears or something
they look like they only [ __ ] missionary
threw a blanket this [ __ ] PJ exactly
I feel like they have a sex blanket
we're in between the other one the other
one the other one the other guy that's
alive right but he looks alike not the
one that's dead all right P I'm so sorry
well if you look alike he left a lot on
so I couldn't tell you looks like this
guy
they look the same he looks like an
older version of naba look look at his
soft nothing but demons back he has no
lips and the other guy does she just
switched from for my Civic DX to a civic
IX like what's the damn difference get
the same [ __ ] that's what it is dude I
don't know but they all known each other
since high school
that's weird get some fresh dick dude
stranger dick is different I don't want
to know them flaws and [ __ ]
I'm not trying to [ __ ] my friends that's
disgusting cuz you know everything huh
yeah they're not sex objects anymore why
would you want to have sex with them I
didn't know part that much so that was
my excuse maybe they're making you guys
work I forget you gotta play space
though yeah so this I forgot about that
I know that sounds like oh no Joe so
they got married in 89 88 or 89 and then
so Mike and Brian went out on a dunk
Dunkin Donuts date a donkey donkey a
duck hunting trip and so Denise got some
white [ __ ] I'm gonna say that the Denise
and Brian had already had an affair for
about three years
why does she just [ __ ] divorce him
why does he have to kill because she
didn't want to be a broke divorcee she
wanted to be a rich widow this [ __ ] is
evil oh wait so that guy does that money
but maybe life insurance exactly it's a
late one six months before Mike died
they they kept taking out life insurance
policies I racked up 200 or 1.7 million
oh yeah and this was like in 2000 so
that's even more money then that's when
Denise convinced Brian to kill Mike
during this duck hunting trip bye so he
was gonna actually do
yeah accidentally so he was gonna be
wearing those waders you know the like
the overall looks like all rubber and so
it was like he's gonna push him off the
boat and because he's wearing the waders
he's gonna drown but then what happened
was that some white people drowning
methods yeah so once you pushed him
overboard
Mike quickly took off his jacket and
took up the waders and he was like
trying to survive he was panicking and
then Brian had his shock in there cuz
they were a duck hunting and so he made
the quick decision to shoot him oh and
then he dragged Mike out from the water
and put him in his SUV drove back home
went to bed next to his wife because his
wife was still sleeping he woke he woke
up and he was like oh I have to go do
something for someone else so then he
left and this whole time he had Mike's
body in his SUV he went and he he went
to go bury Mike's body in this one area
near where Mike grew up so as I call in
the same area it's not a very good
criminal he actually got away with it
for 17 18 years bad cops and so they got
away with it this whole time Denise and
Brian got married after like five years
after Mike's death they got married and
then all this suspicion kind of went to
them like that's kind of weird and oh
because so they never had a body so the
cop said oh maybe he got eaten by an
alligator and that's why we can't find a
body
but then Mike's mom was investigating
this as she was and she spoke to some
alligator professional people and they
were like yeah there's no way they're
gonna eat a whole body in the wintertime
that doesn't happen right no Gator sees
these cops are worse than [ __ ] making
a murder cop yeah cuz that's like so
lazy dude oh we can't find a body
alligator gar next case closed yeah so
then Mike's mom always had like this
weird suspicion towards Denise and by
the way Mike and Denise had a daughter
and the whole time the daughter was
suspicious no she kind of removed the
daughter from Mike's family like kind of
cut ties with them she got married
with Brian then the marriage started
dissolving around 2016 and he was trying
to find another person to kill the guy
No
and that's when Brian started having all
these guilt guilt and he was really
scared that Denise is gonna go to the
cops and tell him about Mike
Wow so how about do it first no so then
what he did was that he got his gun and
he went he putted the gun to her head
and kidnapped her for an hour like took
her in his car and for like this whole
hour they were he was like pretty much
telling her like you better not tell the
cops that I killed my Pig this is your
fault you convinced me to do this so
then he I guess they talked it out and
then she he went to go drop her off at
her car she drove to the authorities and
this [ __ ] is so stupid so by her going
to the cops
Brian ended up confessing the whole
night and they led them to Mike's body
and now Denise was arrested for
conspiracy why is she so stupid what
does she think was gonna happen she's so
[ __ ] dumb yes she went to the cops
and so now Brian is on trial for the
kidnapping for the kidnapping and so the
the cop said hey if you confess all this
[ __ ] about Mike's murder you're gonna
have immunity to Mike's murder hidden
she's gonna be in trouble again we're
gonna get bring her down so she's gonna
have life in prison Wow yeah you got
immunity that yeah there's a lot of
people that has done heinous as crimes
that are at like they're in WITSEC
they're like [ __ ] immune to it like
they have immunity they don't have any
problem so your neighbor or whoever
could have killed like five people or
whatever but because they ratted on an
organization or whoever yeah that
they're just chillin and no one knows
and so now Denise's lawyers are saying
like there's no tangible evidence to
prove that Denise knew about Mike being
killed by Brian like there's no like
right now Mike is just his word against
hers right yeah like Brian is trying to
fight this case like he's just trying to
bring her down with him there's nothing
like that can really prove it and so now
there's this whole trial I say look at
the size of her forehead and judge her
based on that because there's a lot of
evil in that forehead especially the way
the head slopes upwards I don't trust
that [ __ ] yeah that's where all the
diabolical plans are stored yep
slanted it is all the way up to the back
yeah he only has a couple of guy polical
moments yeah but then her she's got like
six or seven more you could literally
[ __ ] slide a toy car off that head
easy like a ramp she's got a little
smirk going on like like this is kind of
an aqueduct right here Angela and Toby
from the office dude oh yeah what I'm
kind of curious about is what happened
to his wife and what happened to his
lips they're all in Iowa yeah he had a
wife and then they don't mention what
happened to her he killed her to it
she's not important they just got
divorced then then maybe should drown to
some waiters - she's important she is
important because they were all four of
them how can you how can you just like
kiss a man like that you can't there's
nothing there it's just like a cartoon
line she has more than him though that
[ __ ] looks like somebody's had a Sharpie
the emoji dude the bottom part of your
lip like the inside when you kiss you
know you can't kiss that build man
there's nothing there dude
[Music]
[Music]